can you tell us the whole story of how
you sold it takes three who did you give
the script to first so the story of how
the
movie came to be
i have a i have a limited perspective
um but the sort of broad strokes are
that
so i wrote it on spec right i assume i
assume the viewers
no know that terminology um
so it was a spec script that i wrote
i wrote it and i do think this is sort
of important i wrote it very
specifically because
i had had enough sort of data and not
like the most hard data but more sort of
anecdotal
data
that
that i had a lot of people who were that
i knew who were looking for something
like this
um
because i and i put that out there
because i think sometimes
specs are very very hard right like most
of the like it
it constantly sort of evolves but like
traditionally like
selling something on spec is a very
difficult thing it just doesn't happen
very often
right like specs are very useful to get
other jobs or again to get
representation they don't very often
actually get sold
and even when they do get sold they
don't very often get produced right it's
not something that happens
every day
and so for me
when i'm writing something on spec i
want to at least go into it knowing okay
when this is done
i know
through however i
what relationships i have
that i've got
at least a handful of people
who would potentially be interested in
something like this or that i know or
i've gotten feedback from
my representation that there's a handful
of people that they know would be
interested in this um
i think it's again you're very brave if
you do it completely in a vacuum
right and i've done that also but it's
just not my like preference um
so i
i knew that like because again
my sort of um
relationships with mostly with people in
digital and there was a sort of push at
the moment for this sort of idea of like
influencer-driven features right and
most influencers are of a certain age
right like they're like teen or like you
know young 20 something and um
and the sort of uh
in the sort of material
that then people want to produce
starring them
has a sort of like um
you know
it's a it tends to be like a more
limited like
window right like it's not they're not
gonna make
you know uh the new terminator starring
like an influencer yet
they might tomorrow
but so
and um
and so basically
knowing um
knowing that
i was like okay like these are the
people i know these are the sort of
things that they're looking for
what do i feel like is a story that like
checks all those boxes
um and also
would be a good story
right
i i was drawn and i actually
i was not the only one with this idea
because literally there was
something like i want to say like
four major adaptations of cyrano de
bergerac said in high school that came
out in the last couple years so a lot of
people had this idea it was definitely
in the like uh
in the air
but to me i was like oh this makes a lot
of sense because this adaptation
um
really has the potential to say
something that previous iterations of it
did not really have to say right
specifically with the sort of like
social media component and the sort of
idea of like
how effectively you could actually
catfish someone and people do this
right like
that the story of cyrano
to me honestly felt more prescient like
and important now than it did in its
inception in its inception it was kind
of just an interesting quirky story
but now it felt like really sort of
important and some like and really like
had a lot to say
um
and so i felt like oh this is again this
feels like it checks off like a lot of
boxes worth doing
um
and so then i
and then i wrote it um and i gave it to
my manager at the time who
who shopped it around to the
relationships he had or the
relationships i had
and a production company like
came on board and then ultimately
it ended up in the hands of gunpowder
and sky
who then ended up uh producing it
and how did you have your manager
already
so my so my manager who was also a
producer on the film uh his name is
kevin herrera and
kevin and i had been working together
because
at the time i had my own uh digital
production company
and
i had been
basically
one of the things that
i was doing was trying to put like it
started as a very sort of one-man band
doing all sorts of just random jobs for
whoever
sort of situation
um but as it sort of grew
i was able to parlay that into actually
um
doing like digital series
right like i like either for like like
branded corporate partners like it was
pretty funny but like uh one of my um
one of my biggest clients was playboy
because playboy literally at the time
uh
people might not remember but they were
trying to do a whole initiative to like
go non-nude and they were like trying to
rebrand um and so we were doing like a
bunch of like sort of sketch comedy for
them and different shows
um and other like
other things like that like uh
we we helped do post-production on a on
a logan paul series
um and then as those opportunities came
up
that then i
i knew kevin um through like mutual
friends
and as those sort of opportunities came
up
it it then allowed
he was able to sort of come in and help
be like oh okay how can we grow this now
right
because like okay so you did happen to
get like this one but like
i can help you get like more i can help
get you more shows i can like you know
um
uh help connect you with more of those
sort of opportunities
and so
we started working together in that
capacity
um
but he also was trying to put together
uh these sort of influencer or
ended up again not going that direction
like young adult
um
driven features
and that's how that sort of relationship
developed
but that again to me is why i'm always
sort of a proponent of like
you don't know what
like
it's important to have your goals and
know what you would like to do right
like i never stopped wanting to
write um
and have features and like and do those
sort of projects
um
but i don't i honestly don't know
that i would have gotten
uh the opportunity to like
to do like a
a feature film or have my spec be like
sold or produced if i was trying to go
through a very traditional
route
um
[Music]
maybe
i mean i i will never know
but
but i do feel like again from my
perspective there's always something to
be about like okay like
this is a sort of
this is another sort of street that
people aren't taking
and like and so
as long as i know where i want to go
like
and i'm having those discussions with
the people like i'm like you know
my like uh professional like like
counterparts and peers
like
those opportunities like still like
exist not always where you're looking i
guess sure do you take fountain
sometimes okay if that one's backed up a
lot they always say that's an
alternative yeah it's it's always
evolving that's the that's the i will
say that that's like uh even like that's
a
a joke but it is it's always it's always
changing
and i think that it's important to like
remember that too because like again the
the way that that project came together
would it come together like that again
today
maybe i don't know
like
i'm like
like uh
if you asked me like a hundred percent
would it like would that happen again no
i don't think like again
things always are like literally like
you know
he's all that uh without alison ray also
came out like last month like things
always like
similar things do like happen
but you just you don't
you know uh and forgive me if i'm wrong
but i but allison ray is a tick-tock
star right and like when i was like
writing like
it takes three there's
that wasn't like uh that wasn't a thing
so you know i think that it is it's very
it's always moving very quickly um
and it behooves everyone to
[Music]
pay attention to that
and to not think that something that
worked i do think it's a mis it's not
necessarily the most savvy mood to go
like move to go like oh well this is how
like quentin tarantino did it yes it is
in like
in like 1990
like
i i
i wouldn't
i i don't know
the odds of it happening like that same
way again are are not like great because
it's just an entirely different
environment you know where were you when
you got the news that the script was
sold i don't know
i'm sure i was at my office i'm sure i
was doing work um
it was
it was very like it was very exciting
and it was very cool um i think it was
very interesting to me because
because it was my
because again my digital company was my
full-time job
i don't know that i ever really like
relish in it as much
as like
i might have been otherwise because just
literally i didn't
i was on productions and i had things to
do
um
i do with the caveat of i do think it's
always really important to
celebrate whatever small wins you get
i feel like um
there's so much sort of emphasis on if
you if you don't
achieve
the like the final stage
right that like all everything you did
all the work
um
it doesn't like matter and there's so
many steps along the way that are like
ridiculously huge accomplishments
like that you might not even recognize
as like big accomplishments
and like
but you should
you know
i i feel like
i feel like
i feel like it's very exciting when like
when you've
literally like on the on the list of 10
000 items you finally like cross like
number 10 000
but not every project goes there and not
and that doesn't mean
that if you got to like number like 8
that all of that was
a bad use of time or that that's not
worth celebrating there's all sorts of
very positive um things that happen
along the way in ways that you might not
even under like
you might not even understand in the
moment
right
like how they'll like pay off later or
like
or or why they're important
um
that's something i do like i really like
believe in a lot is like
again like
celebrate
everything
that's a that's a step
some people are very don't count your
chickens before they're hatched i i
don't care i if they if they never hatch
i still got some awesome eggs and i'm
really excited about my eggs
they don't turn into chickens they don't
turn into chickens i'm still gonna like
you know i'm still gonna feel positive
about
where it is right now
you